Hello.
Hello. We are KANA-BOON. Hi.
Thanks for having us.
Thank you.
I'm Maguro Taniguchi, lead vocals and
guitarist for KANA-BOON. Hello. And then...
I'm Takahiro Koizumi.
Right.
I'm the guitarist, Hayato Koga.
I'm the bassist, Mashi.
Good morning, good afternoon,
and good evening. How's everyone doing?
Good morning. Hello.
Good morning, good afternoon,
and good evening. How's everyone doing?
We have some questions here.
Okay.
"How did your group form?"
I see. Our formation story.
When we were 16-year-old
first-years in high school,
we met through our
school's light music club.
I said I wanted to form a band,
and Koi-chan sat next to me.
We sat next to each other.
That's how we met.
And I didn't bring any pencils
on my first day of high school.
You sure didn't.
So I asked Koi-chan to lend me a pen.
Then, we joined the
light music club together.
And these two...
We're childhood friends.
Since grade school.
Koi-chan told me he'd been
invited to join a band...
or rather, invited to
join the light music club,
so I thought, "Maybe I'll join the club, too."
It was like a domino effect.
The first band the three of us
formed together was KANA-BOON.
Yeah.
And we met Mashi in second year.
I was a second-year at another
high school, but we became friends.
For a long time after that, I was either
living with Maguro or hanging out as friends.
You joined the band last year.
Last April.
In April 2022, you became a member.
Yes.
And now, the four of us work together.
Yeah.
Next one's about Naruto.
Naruto? Okay.
A lot of foreign fans learned
of KANA-BOON through Naruto.
The people watching this
probably like Naruto, too.
Yeah.
It's one of Japan's biggest anime series.
"Could you tell us your highlights
of providing music for Naruto?"
So, like memories, I guess.
Naruto's "Silhouette" was the
first song we wrote for an anime.
We were so happy.
So happy.
Sorry, Mashi. You weren't in the band then.
Right.
So this is just for the three of us.
The Naruto manga started
while we were still in grade school.
We got really excited
following the series in real time.
Really excited, yeah.
We got really excited
following the series in real time.
So working on Naruto had been
a dream of ours since we debuted.
When that came true and we went to
the SONY Music office together, I cried.
It's not often that you get to
experience something that moving,
so I was very happy about it.
Mashi, you watched KANA-BOON do all that.
Your popularity exploded, and you started
appearing all over the place, including on TV.
I was watching all of that while
working my regular part-time job.
People get really excited
for this song at shows,
which always reminds me
how great and significant it is for us.
People get really excited for "Silhouette."
They even sing it in Japanese.
This was true when we released
the song and it's still true today,
but it always moves us in fresh ways.
Okay.
Oh, I like this question.
It's about the Naruto game.
"NARUTO SHIPPUDEN: Ultimate Ninja
STORM 4's 'Spiral' is awesome," it says.
Thank you.
"'Silhouette' is also awesome."
"Could you explain the process
of writing songs and music for Naruto?"
Our connection with
Naruto is kind of special.
We followed the manga
and anime in real time.
We never really felt any pressure.
We're able to naturally produce songs
just by thinking about what
Naruto and Boruto mean to us.
We think a little more about the original work
when we create songs for other series.
We've written about five songs for Naruto,
and we've been able to do it
in a natural and relaxed way.
We have a kind of mysterious
affinity with the series.
You know, like Rasengan.
Right. For the Naruto series, I pay extra
attention to the scenery and technique names,
and draw inspiration from them.
I've written phrases trying to
capture the sound of Rasengan.
He's the one guy in the band
who can produce a Rasengan.
I can?
Yeah. Yeah, you can.
Okay.
"We've heard you're big fans of Naruto."
Yes, of course.
"How does it feel to
perform Naruto songs live?"
Is there anything we think or feel as fans?
I mentioned it just now,
but when I write songs or phrases,
I think about the techniques
and scenery that appear in Naruto.
I think about those things while playing, too.
I imagine the opening animation
in my head while I'm playing.
But when I saw how excited fans were
in Canada, Indonesia, and Saudi Arabia,
I couldn't even think about that anymore.
I wanted to connect with
the people right in front of me.
When we performed overseas,
I found myself most often thinking
about the original author, Mr. Kishimoto.
We've met and spoken to
Naruto's original author, Mr. Kishimoto.
When we wrote the song "Diver"
and performed it at an event,
Mr. Kishimoto cried tears of joy.
I remember that specific moment.
So when we perform "Silhouette" overseas,
I think about Mr. Kishimoto.
Wow.
Like, "Thank you for bringing us here," and,
"I wish I could show this to Mr. Kishimoto."
Yeah. That's what I think about.
"Aside from Naruto, you've written
songs for a variety of anime series,
including My Hero Academia, Fire Force,
and more recently, Zom 100."
Yeah, Zom 100. including My Hero Academia, Fire Force,
including My Hero Academia, Fire Force,
and more recently, Zom 100."
"When you first started out, did you imagine
you'd end up working on so many amazing series?"
"Did you expect this to happen?"
No, no, no.
No?
No, definitely not.
No, we didn't.
We always wanted to be a good cool band,
but we never expected to
work on so many anime series.
Even when we wrote "Silhouette" for Naruto,
we didn't expect to write
so many more songs for anime series.
We wanted to work on Naruto,
so that was something we could imagine,
but working on all these other series
isn't something we imagined.
Yeah. It's strange, isn't it?
It is.
KANA-BOON and anime.
I guess we're very compatible.
Okay.
"The video for My Hero Academia's
'Starmarker' featuring the disco ball man..."
The disco ball man?
His name is Starman.
The person who wrote this question
really likes the music video.
Thank you.
It's interesting, isn't it?
That person is a professional dancer.
A pro dancer.
What they did wearing that
shiny silver costume was amazing.
Right.
We got to see them dance.
It was interesting.
"How much are you involved in
the creation of the music videos?"
For the most part,
the film director makes the decisions.
Yeah.
For the most part,
the film director makes the decisions.
The film director for the project
tells everyone what to do.
Our own director and the film director
work together to come up with a proposal.
We've been involved in
a lot of challenging film shoots,
but we do whatever we're told.
Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
"Are there any concepts you'd like
to try in future music videos?"
What if one of us directed?
You mean one of us?
Koi-chan's done it before, right?
Once. As a parody.
Right, it was a parody.
It was done in a jokey way.
What kind of video would
you make if you directed?
I was the primary subject
of the video I made.
All the other members turned into me.
So this time, I wouldn't be in it.
I'd rather think about
what I'd have everyone else do.
And you wouldn't be in it?
You wouldn't be playing instruments.
You'd be acting instead.
So like a drama?
You wouldn't be playing instruments.
You'd be acting instead.
Like a drama?
Yeah, I'd make it like a drama.
What would we play?
Well, it would depend on the concept.
Koga would probably make
the most interesting lead.
Me?
Yeah, Koga. But Maguro acts a lot,
so I'd have Koga play the lead,
and you'd play his girlfriend.
I'm his girlfriend?
And you're the dad.
Why?
So I could watch over them?
Exactly.
I wanna make these two go skydiving.
No, no, no. No way.
"Could you tell us about any
future projects, albums, or tours?"
Well, this fall, we'll be visiting
47 locations across Japan.
We'll be touring everywhere.
We're going all over, yeah.
We did it once five years ago.
Since this year is our tenth anniversary,
we're doing it again.
As far as releases go, there's Zom 100's
theme song, "Song of the Dead."
We're always thinking about how
we'd like to produce an album, too.
As soon as we say that, someone
will make us do it, so it's not easy.
But we do always want to write new songs.
We always have that energy.
As for overseas performances... We'd like to.
We'd like to go.
We were invited to go to South America
at the end of the year. In the fall, I think.
Thank you.
But we have our domestic tour,
so our schedule didn't allow it.
We'd like to go next year, though.
Yeah.
We'd like to visit new places,
though it'd be nice to return to
Saudi Arabia, Indonesia, and Canada, too.
Lots of places we want to go.
There are places we'd like
to visit for the first time, too,
so we hope someone
will invite us. Thank you.
Thank you.
"It's time for a bunch
of rapid-fire questions."
Favorite anime?
Cowboy Bebop.
Right.
I got really into it as a kid.
The opening is just so cool.
I know what you mean.
That's it.
It taught me a lot about
how cool an opening can be.
The show's great, too.
Favorite anime?
Naruto is my number one,
but I also like the ODDTAXI anime.
I really like the deductive reasoning
and the way the story progresses.
ODDTAXI is a great series.
Favorite anime?
Rokudenashi Blues.
There's an anime?
There is, yeah.
I didn't know there was an anime.
Yeah, I've only seen the manga.
It's, you know...
I like stories about youth.
Stories about youth?
About men having passionate
conversations with their fists.
It's a manga about street fighting.
Yeah.
Koi-chan likes that kind of stuff.
I like, uh... Magical DoReMi.
I wonder if foreigners know that one.
The theme song's called "Ojamajo Carnival!!"
It's an amazing song.
My dream is to create a song that good.
No song is as catchy
or amazing as that song.
"Who is currently the
top artist in your playlist?"
"Who do you listen to most these days?"
Right now, I'm listening to The Hives.
They released a new album
recently. It's really cool.
You've liked them for a while.
Yeah, I have, but I've been
listening to them a lot lately.
What about you?
I've been listening to WurtS.
A young Japanese artist.
We competed against him in a battle of the bands,
and I've been listening to his music ever since.
He's really cool.
And you, Koi-chan?
Joe Hisaishi.
Who?
The Ghibli guy.
Ghibli, huh?
I've been listening to him a lot.
Lately, I've been thinking the composition
and flow of his music is astounding.
So I've been listening to his orchestral
tracks and thinking they're amazing.
Wasn't expecting that.
Koi-chan, that's what you're into?
Unexpected, but I can see it.
It's really good.
It's fantastical.
I listened to him a lot in Canada.
Listen to some Canadian bands.
Wow.
I just checked who I've listened to most
so far in 2023, and it was the Foo Fighters.
Right, Foo Fighters.
I just checked who I've listened to most
so far in 2023, and it was the Foo Fighters.
Right, Foo Fighters.
It's probably them every year.
They released a new album, too.
That's what I've been listening to.
Yeah.
They released a new album, too.
That's what I've been listening to.
"If you could become a Naruto
character, who would you be?"
You're Choji, right?
I'd definitely be Choji.
You're practically Choji now.
I look like this now
because I want to be Choji.
You'd have to lose some weight.
It's not like you can actually become Choji.
Who would you be?
I'd like to be Rock Lee.
I've always liked martial arts
and I used to practice a little bit.
I wish I could have his agility.
Koga actually does karate.
A long time ago, yeah.
You, Mashi?
It's hard to choose, but I think
I'd want to be Shikamaru.
I'm drawn to intelligent characters.
You want to know his thought process.
And have his observation skills.
He's a strategist.
Strategist characters are cool.
Then, who should I be?
Ramen Ichiraku's...
The store owner?
I'll be the owner of Ramen Ichiraku.
But I'm probably Naruto.
Yeah.
I do see myself in him.
"What do you sing most often at karaoke?"
Ulfuls, maybe?
Ulfuls.
Yeah, Ulfuls.
Oh, are you done?
What do you sing?
"Aoi Bench" by Sasuke.
Oh, Sasuke? Different
from the Sasuke in Naruto.
Yeah, not him. It's confusing.
I frequently sing a song called
"Aoi Bench" by Sasuke, the music artist.
Koi-chan?
"TEGAMI" by HY.
We've heard Koi-chan's
"TEGAMI" a bunch of times.
Ever since high school.
You love that song.
I sing a lot of Asian Kung-Fu Generation.
I sing all their songs.
"Team Uzumaki or Team Uchiha?"
From Naruto.
I can't choose.
If I had to be affiliated with one, then...
"Affiliated with"?
If I had to live with one,
it would be the Uzumaki family.
Is it that deep?
No? Isn't that what they're asking?
I don't think it's meant to be that deep.
Just in general, then?
I think it's simply
whose story do you prefer.
I think I'm Team Uchiha.
They're cool. Their eyes are cool.
The Sharingan.
Yeah, the Sharingan.
Koi-chan?
Team Uzumaki, for sure.
Yeah. I'm Team Uzumaki, too.
Yeah, I know.
I'm Team Uzumaki, too.
But your clothes are Team Uchiha.
Yeah.
Your hairstyle's Team Uchiha, too.
Yeah, but I want a peaceful life.
A peaceful life?
This is a tough question.
"In a word, how would you describe KANA-BOON?"
What?
That is tough.
I'd like someone else to tell us.
Describe KANA-BOON in a word.
How would you describe KANA-BOON?
"Love"?
Love? What's he trying to say?
You're just showing off.
No, not at all.
We receive love from our fans,
and we're currently expressing
our love for all kinds of things.
I feel love in everything,
like the audience and our shows.
That's true.
In a word. That's tough.
For me, it's "friends."
The band formed because we were friends,
and we're still friends to this day.
So in a word, it's "friends."
"Friendship."
Because we're friends?
"Friends" makes sense to me, too.
It's the upgraded version of what I said.
The four of us are friends, but there's
the relationship with our audience, too.
Instead of being separated into artist
and audience, we're closer than that.
We're a band that's close to our audience.
So in that regard, I think
it's "friendship" or "friends."
You're right.
My word is "friends."
Seriously? Friends?
There's that closeness Koi-chan mentioned.
I want to be as close
as possible with our audience.
We don't particularly
want to become rock stars.
We're not trying to become
people fans worship.
But we always want to be there
for our fans who listen to and watch us.
We want to be rock heroes.
That's that.
What are these?
Candy?
They're sticks.
Sticks. They're sticks.
Pointer sticks.
We're going to be asked some questions.
We'll use these to point to whoever
we think the question applies to.
Okay, got it.
We'll point at the same time.
Let's give it a try.
"Who'd make the best Hokage?"
Ready, and...
Wait, wait. Let me think.
"Who would make the best Hokage?"
Ready, and...
Huh? Did we all choose different people?
I chose Koi-chan. What about you, Koi-chan?
Mashi.
Me?
Who'd Mashi choose?
Maguro.
And I chose myself.
You chose yourself?
Why'd you choose yourself?
I think I could govern.
The rest of you don't seem like
you'd be able to govern a country.
But you think you'd be
able to govern a country?
I'm good at organizing things.
We're talking on a way bigger scale, though.
You're not tidying up a room.
Setting aside popularity, I thought in terms
of what was and wasn't possible.
Right. Popularity's another matter.
Setting aside popularity, I thought in terms
of what was and wasn't possible.
Who could get the job done.
Right. Popularity's another matter.
Like the office work?
Out of all of us, I think I could
handle the office work best.
"Who could eat more ramen than Naruto?"
I wonder.
Who is it?
Ready, and...
You're just basing it on my build.
You seem like you could.
I never order extra noodles. Seriously.
Isn't this made of ramen?
No. I know what I look like,
but it's actually Mashi who eats a ton.
It's true that I do eat the most.
Mashi eats the most in front of others,
and Koi-chan eats the most in secret.
I don't, even in secret.
I don't eat that much ramen.
It's true that I look like
I'd eat the most, though. I get it.
"Who finds new music to listen to?"
Ready, and...
It's Maguro. Yeah.
That's true. I'll recommend
stuff I think is good.
But I get a lot of recommendations from Mashi.
It was a choice between you two.
I do make a lot of recommendations, too.
There's that pop punk playlist
you sent me the other day.
When we flew to Canada,
I listened to it the whole way.
"Who would survive a zombie apocalypse?"
Ready, and...
We're divided.
You chose Koga?
I chose Koga.
Koga, huh.
I feel like I'd die first.
You seem like you'd hide forever.
But I'd run out of food.
You seem like you'd have something prepared.
In advance?
Yeah, in advance.
He'd know it was coming?
He would.
You're on another level. You've been
watching zombie stuff for way longer.
The two of us have watched
a lot of zombie movies.
You've got zombie knowledge.
You know way more.
We've seen Zombieland.
We know what to do.
We've got that know-how.
"Who'd be the best Gundam pilot?"
Which member would be
the best Gundam pilot?
Ready, and...
Should we battle?
I like Gundam.
Between the two of you,
who'd be the better pilot?
I'm simply a good pilot.
It's not like you've piloted one.
I'm good at piloting machines.
You can use a forklift.
Yeah, I've got a forklift license.
I've got a standard license.
Not good enough.
So do I.
Koga's got a special license.
Someday, KANA-BOON will go on a world tour.
We'd like to.
Yeah, we'd like to.
We're currently traveling
all over in order to achieve that,
so if you know us and listen to
our music, let's meet someday.
Wait for us. Thank you.
Thank you.
We are KANA-BOON.